heute startet in bangkok die
un-klimakonferenz zur vorbereitung des
weltklimagipfels im polnischen kattowitz
im dezember dabei herrscht in thailand
alarmstimmung
der vorsitzende der konferenz fidschis
ministerpräsident frank bainimarama
kritisiert dass dem pariser
klimaabkommen keine taten gefolgt sind
ist die klimakatastrophe noch
aufzuhalten klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen heute ist quasi
weltklima tag hier bei pixum heute abend
um 18 uhr unser klima stream zu dem ich
mich sehr freue marcel von den
attentätern dabei zu haben und um 1730
der livestream schon hierfür kanal
mitglieder und patterns in den streams
habe ich übrigens eine brandaktuelle und
ausnahmsweise mal positive nachricht für
euch seid gespannt und unser video heute
zum klimawandel was ist also los nichts
muss man provozieren zusammenfassen der
klimaschutz kommt einfach nicht voran
wenn es so weitergeht dann klima wandeln
wir unseren blauen planeten so dass er
eben nicht mehr blau ist sondern
verdorrt und die menschheit das nicht
überleben wird einen vorgeschmack gab es
schon jetzt so sei deutschland von oben
aus jetzt im sommer nachdem alexander
gerst in der internationalen raumstation
iss einige wochen immer nachts über
deutschland geflogen war machte er am 6
august diese aufnahmen gas dazu
schockierender anblick alles vertrocknet
und braun was eigentlich grün sein
sollte und das betrifft in diesem sommer
die komplette nordhalbkugel zum ersten
mal seitdem wir das wetter beobachten
war die gesamte nordhalbkugel in einem
sommer heiß zitat davon sind wir alle
überrascht worden und wir können derzeit
nicht sagen ob das ein phänomen ist dass
wir häufiger erwarten müssen aber das
heißt nicht dass es nicht passiert nur
dass wir es noch nicht wissenschaftlich
belegen können so anders levermann vom
potsdam institut für
klimafolgenforschung
doch zum ersten mal lehnt sich ein
klimaforscher extrem aus dem fenster
motiv latif einer der führenden
wissenschaftler auf dem gebiet des
klimawandels in deutschland bisher war
immer extrem zurückhaltend und mit
konkrete bezüge zwischen wetter und
klima selbst im letzten jahr als der
durch den klimawandel verlangsamt
jak si mit einer rost die welle die
dadurch stärker in den süden reichen
einen unwetter nach deutschland
katapultierte vermied es latif einen
konkreten zusammenhang herzustellen und
ja das ist wissenschaftlich absolut
korrekt denn das konkret diese roski
welle durch den klimawandel verursacht
wurde
das kann niemand konkret nachweisen
wobei der zusammenhang schon ziemlich
deutlich ist aber latif ist
wissenschaftler ganz klar doch jetzt
attraktiv seine zurückhaltung aufgegeben
die hitze in diesem sommer findet latif
zitat außergewöhnlich weil sie schon so
lange anhält es bestätige sich mehr und
mehr was wir klimaforscher lange
vorausgesagt haben und das in bezug auf
den klimawandel in deutschland so der
professor am kieler helmholtz-zentrum
für ozeanforschung zur passauer neuen
presse
wetter und klimawandel lassen sich also
immer konkreter in einen zusammenhang
bringen und die politik versagt wir
haben ja gerade über eine von greenpeace
beauftragte studie des fraunhofer
instituts für energiewirtschaft und
energiesystemtechnik berichtet these
deutschland kann seine klimaziele noch
locker erreichen wenn kohlekraftwerke
abgeschaltet oder gedrosselt werden und
das ohne gefährdung der
versorgungssicherheit aber die politik
tut einfach nichts es ist wirklich
hochnotpeinlich wenn brandenburgs
ministerpräsident dietmar woidke von der
spd warnt zitat ein schneller
kohleausstieg stärkt die afd
dann zeigt er damit nur eins er ist kein
politiker überspitzt formuliert er nimmt
also die vernichtung der menschheit in
kauf damit die afg nicht stärker wird
das ist aber sein verdammter job als
politiker das zu verhindern was sind das
für lappen bei den etablierten parteien
angela merkel hat vor der letzten
bundestagswahl ihr versprechen dazu
gegeben zitat wir werden wege finden wie
wir ist 2020 unser 40 ziel einhalten das
verspreche ich ihnen ja scheint sie
jetzt nicht mehr sonderlich zu
interessieren denn von diesem klimaziel
sind wir meilenweit entfernt macht also
mit und unterzeichnet die petition bei
change.org und hier geht es wirklich
nicht um irgendeine politische
entscheidung oder meinung ich denke dass
linke wie rechte und alle dazwischen die
zukunft der menschheit retten wollen es
geht nur um eins kann ich logisch denken
verstehe das prinzip von wissenschaft
und damit die klimaforschung oder habe
ich in der schule
nicht richtig aufgepasst und vertraut
verschwörungstheorien erstere also
einfach hier draufklicken und wenn ihr
den klima stream heute nicht verpassen
wollt dann ist hier der link dazu
mitglieder und patterns bekommen zu
ihrem stream noch eine extra nachricht
mehr collection gibt's heute nicht bis
dann bleibt dran